ونحييكم مشاهدينا الى هذه الضغط المستمره
للتطورات في السودان الحل في السودان يبدو
بعيد المنال وفقا للارهاصات على الارض
فاكره الطرفين يعتبر اللانهايه للقتال الا
بانتصاره واستسلام الغريب وبينما تستنزف
موارد السودان وتستهلك قواه العسكريه
والاقتصاديه والطبيه يستمر السودانيون
بالنزوح عن ديارهم خارج الخرطوم نحو اماكن
اكثر امنا لا تسقط فيها قذيفه على بيوتهم
ولا تقطع العمليات العسكريه او لا تقطع
عنهم ماء او كهرباء او غذاء تغطيتنا
مستمره مشاهدينا للاحداث في السودان فاهلا
بكم الى هذه الساعه الجديده
[موسيقى]
على الرغم من الدعوات الدوليه المتجدده
لوقف اطلاق النار في السودان استمرت
الاشتباكات بين الجيش السوداني وقوات
الدعم السريع التي اندلعت في الخامس عشر
من ابريل واليكم لمحه عامه عن خريطه الوضع
الميداني بحسب مكتب الشؤون الانسانيه
للامم المتحده فان الاشتباكات العنيفه
تمركزت في العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم
وكذلك في بحري اما في الفاشر بولايه شمال
دارفور فقد شهدت الشبكات المتقطعه بين
طرفي الصراع باستخدام الاسلحه الثقيله
والخفيفه لجانب الاحياء في واد مدني
بولايه الجزيره حذرت من اشتباكات بين
الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع على طول الطريق
من الخرطوم والى مدنيه الذي كان احد الطرق
الرئيسيه التي يستخدمها النازحون من
العاصمه ونتيجه الاشتباكات المستمره
ونتيجه لنقص السلع الاساسيه كذلك نجح بين
10 الى 20,000 شخص هم من النساء والاطفال
الى تشاد المجاوره وفقا لمفوضيه الامم
المتحده لشؤون اللاجئين مكتب شؤون
الانسانيه بالامم المتحده رصد مقتل
اربعمائه وثلاثه عشر شخصا واصابه 3500
اخرين في الاشتباكات حتى الوحده والعشرين
من ابريل الجاريه وذكر تقرير للمكتبه ان
الخرطومه سجلت اعلى عدد من القتلى
ب122 ثم ولايه شمال كردفان بخمس وتسعين
قتيلا وشمال دارفور بواحد وستين قتيلا ومع
استمرار الاقتتال لا يزال عدد القتلى
مرشحا للزياده
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
قال المتحدث باسم قوات الدعم السريع في
السودان ان قوته نفذ الظهر الاحد عمليه
اجلاء جريحين من الرعايه اليونانيين الى
مقر السفارات الفرنسيه وذلك بعد ان تعرض
لغاره من طيران الجيش السوداني حسب ما جاء
على لسان المتحدث باسم الدعم السريع
نتابع ونرى تطورات على الارض مع زمينه
مراسل العربيه سالمه الهاشمي من الخرطوم
سالم اهلا بك معنا اشتباكات متقطعه ووتيره
في نسق مختلف عن مشاهدناه بالامس وفي
الايام حتى السابقه حدثنا عن الصوره واخر
التفاصيل من عندك فيما يخص هذه الاشتباكات
وخاصه استهدفات القذائف كيف هي
نعم
تشهد
ربما اكثر الايام منذ بدا هذه الاشتباكات
رغم انه في بدعه شهدت بعض المناطق في
العاصمه الخرطوم
متعدده وايضا هجمات الطائرات لكن بعد قصه
توترات هذه الاحداث منذ الساعه الحاديه
عشره عنه حتى الان تشهد هدوءا يعني حذف
لمناطق متعدده ايضا في العصر
تشهد حياه اشبه بالطبيعيه بشكل كامل لكنها
قريبه من الطبيعيه تماما في حين المناظر
تتجدد فيها الاشتباكات دائما تشهد المناطق
هدوءا حذرا وايضا عدم خروج الى الشارع
بالاضافه الى اغلاق للمحل التجاريه في تلك
ربما هذه ابرزه الاحداث حتى طيب سالم لما
تقول بان بعض المناطق تشهد عوده شبهه
طبيعيه للحياه العاديه حدثنا اكثر عن
التفاصيل بمعنى هل هناك اماكن مؤمنه اكثر
من غيرها هل عادت الحركه بمعنى ان
السودانيين قادرون ان يتجولون قادرون
ربما
يتمكنون من ابتضاء احتياجاتهم الاساسيه
حدثنا اكثر عن التفاصيل خاصه فيما يهم هذه
الحياه اشبه طبيعيه التي تحدثت عنها
في الحياه شبه طبيعيه المناطق البعيده
للمناطق الاشتباكات سواء وهي في الغالب في
ام درمان او في الخرطوم كذلك في المناطق
البعيده من اماكن كذلك هذه المناطق تشهد
هدوء او
طبيعيه بمعنى انه هناك حركه لكنها
بحكم ان المواطنين لا يملكون للحركه
للحركه بشكل طبيعي ثم لا يوجد اي جسر من
الجسور مفتوح بالكليه عدا جسرين من الجسور
من الخرطوم او ثلاثه جسور تهي متباعده
تماما فالحركه تبدو شبه مقيده الى ذلك ان
هناك ندره في بعض السلع الاساسيه
سلعه الوقود نفسها وكذلك الاجره في القمح
او الدقيق ودقيقه القمح وبالاضافه الى
التي تشهد العديد من المحله اما المناطق
التي
والاحياء التي تشهد الاشتباكات كذلك هي
محلته رقائق من الصعوبه الحركه فيها ولا
توجد فيها محل تجاريه تعمل الا نادر جدا
هذا فيما يخص رصد الوضع الميداني هل لديك
بعض المعلومات الاضافيه سالم بخصوص عمليات
الاجلاء في اخر التطورات فرنسا كانت اعلنت
بانها
ستجلي مئه مواطن في انتظار ان تجري مئه
اخرين في وقت لاحق هل من تفاصيل اضافيه
كيف تسير هذه العمليه ما هي هل مطار
الخرطوم كذلك يمكن من عمليه الاجلاء ام
لتوقفه ستتم العمليه بحرا او برا
بيه والاكثر فيه ربما يكون عبره ميناء
السودان وحتى مطار سودان في شرق السودان
لحكم انه هو المطار المؤهل ان في السودان
والاكثر تاهيلا وكذلك لم يتضرر منذ بدا
هذه الاشتباكات لاي شكل من الاشكال كذلك
ايضا فربما يكون الاجلاء غالي ولا اقول
كله طالبيته سيكون في اتجاه الشرق تجاري
يبقى الموضوع والتحدي كذلك فقط
افهم المزيد من المعلومات معك فيما يخص
التصريحات الفرنسيه خاصه التي تقول بانها
ستجلي رعاياها بطائرات عبر مطار يبعد 20
كم عن الخرطوم نحن نتحدث عن اي مطار وهل
هو مؤمن
مطالب من الخرطوم هناك المطارات التي تبعد
عن الخرطوم القريبه من الخرطوم كلها
هي كلها مطارات
تتبع للجيش السوداني وهي مطارات عسكريه في
قاعده عسكريه على الجيش السوداني بهذه
العباره الصحيحه يعني قواعد تتبع للجيش
السوداني والقوات الجويه السودانيه مطار
الخرطوم اذا كان يعني هو يعني مجموعه من
الاضرار لكن كثير من المختص على انه يمكن
اصلاح هذه الاضرار في غضون ايام
استقرت الاوضاع بعد ذلك بالنسبه بشكل عام
سيكون الاجلاء متنوع هناك سيكون بالطيران
يكون تاكيد وربما ايضا يكون هناك من
مطارات مختلفه لكن الاغلب انا ذكرت ان
الاغلب ربما
ومطار بورسودان بحكم انهما اكثر امنا
الاستقرار في بور سوداني ماء كبير جدا
لذلك وايضا تمت عمليات لا ناجح مطار ومن
ميناء بورسودان كذلك في الايام ستستمر هذه
العملات عطفا عليها هناك عمليه نزوح كذا
من المواطنين من داخل وسط الخرطوم الى
اطرافها وحتى الى خارج ولايه الخرطوم الى
ولايه مجاوره اكثر امنه يضاف اليها بعض
ايضا التحركات كذلك لدول المجاوره ايضا
ماذا عن الوسطات سالم كان هناك اخبار متفا
رقه بان هناك جهات في الداخل سوداني تقدم
بعض
الوسطات او تقترح على الاقل هل هذا مؤكد
نتحدث عن اي جهات
نعم هناك
تطرح بين الفين والاخرى من قوه سياسيه
مختلفه في السودان عن الوساطه من اجل
الوصول الى حل منها في هذه القضيه لكن الى
هذه اللحظه لم لم يعني يظهر بادره من
الطرفين
يعني لقبول هذه الوساطه على الارض ليس
للاستجابه فقط تكون موجوده وهناك تلميحات
كثيره جدا من الجانبين بانهم يعني يتقبلون
ذلك لكن على الارض ليس هذا الامر واضحا
لان هذه المبادرات وهذه الوصافات لن تكون
ذات اهم وذات
اهميه ووضوح كذلك اذا لمست وقفا لاطلاق
النار حقيقي بين الجامع التزام الطرفين
بهذا الوقت كذلك لفتره ايصال كل المساعدات
الانسانيه فتح الطرق والممرات كذلك
الطبيه للمستشفيات تغذيه
المحل التجاريه الاسواق بالمواد الغذائيه
حركه المحروقات
حدث هذا الامر ربما يفهم منه ان هنا يمكن
ان يتحدث او ان الوساطات تحدث اختراقا
كبيرا تستطيع ان تصل الى اتفاق بين
الجانبين اود شكرا جزيلا شكر سالم الهاشمي
مراسل العربيه كنت معنا من الخرطوم نعود
لك في سياق نشرتنا ضمن هذه التغطيه
للتطورات في السودان ونشير مشاهدينا الى
هذا العاجل الدفاع الالماني تتحدث عن اول
طائره عسكريه تابعه لها هبطت بالخرطوم
لاجلاء رعياها كنا منذ قليل نتحدث عن
عمليات الاجلاء المستمره والان نشير الى
هذا العاجل عن الدفاع الالمانيه التي تقول
ان اول طائره عسكريه تابعه لها هبطت
بالخرطوم لاجلاء رعاياها وسنتابع كل هذه
الاخبار لحظه بلحظه وكل هذه العواجل كذلك
نتابع وننقل هذه النقاط
لاستطلاع اكثر قربا لما يحدث مع الصحفي
عمار ابو شيبه من الخرطوم بحري عمار اهلا
بك معنا اسمح لي ان ابدا معك بهذه العواجل
عمليه الاجلاء مستمره وهناك بين الفينه
والاخرى بعض التصريحات التي تاتينا
وتخبرنا اكثر عن تفاصيلها وتطوراتها فرنسا
تحدثت من قبلها المملكه العربيه السعوديه
والان الدفاع الالمانيه تقول ان او ان اول
طائره عسكريه تابعه لها هبطت بالخرطوم
لاجلاء رعيها هل من تفاصيل اضافيه معك
نعم يعني حينما نشاهد هذه العمليات عمليات
الاجلاء بكثافه داخل عاصمه الخرطوم خاصه
واننا ربما فشلنا في
ان تستمر الهدنه يعني مجتمع عام في ان
تستمر هذه الغنه علينا او فشل العسكريين
بشكل ادق قد تستمر هذه الهدنه وهنالك
عمليات اجلاء بهذه الكثافه وهنالك عمليه
نوعيه قبل قليل بحسب العاليه التي ذكرتيه
بان الدفاع الالمانيه استطاعت ان تجري او
تنزل طائره في الخرطوم هذا يعني او يوضح
التقارير الامنيه لهذه الاعساد اشارته
بشكل ربما دقيق هو واضح الا ان استحاله
يعني عمليه التقارب ما بين القوتين في هذه
اللحظه وهذا ايضا يشير ويبرر الحديث الذي
كان يتحدث على ان هذه الحرب لابد ان يكون
فيها احد المنتصرا على الاخر وبحسب مص
الرايين ماذا لا يتمسكان بالعمل الحرب
بكخيار اول ربما يكون هناك خيار ثاني
وحديث بحسب التصريحات التي شاهدناها
بالامس للسيد البرهان والسيد حميد انهم
نعم يدعوان لوقف الحرب ولكن ما زال الخيار
العسكري عبر الواقع واقع هو الخيار الاول
وهذا ما يدعو لها المجتمع الدولي كذلك
ولكن عمار عاده الحديث عن اجلاء الرعايه
والبدء في تطبيق عمليات الاجلاء يوحي بان
هذه المعارك
ليست لها نهايه قريبه اولا وهناك اشتداد
للمعارك ربما هل هذا التفكير او هذا
المنطق هو نفسه ما يحس به او
نفسه ما يمكن ان يذهب له بالتفكير
السودانيون في الداخل من خلال متابعاتهم
لهذه الاشتباكات وان كانت متقطعه ولكنها
اخذه في الاتساع
نعم يعني اغلبيه السودانيين الان وربما
يطرحون سؤال مهما يعني طالما وقفت حده هذه
المعارك حتى يتم الا عدد من الرعايه
الاجانب داخل البلاد كان يمكن ان تمرر في
ذات اللحظات وفي ذات الاوقات عدد من
الممرات الامنه لاصلاح عدد من قطاعات
المياه او الكهرباء التي ضل يعاني منها
عدد من احياء ولايه الخرطوم بشكل كبير نعم
جميع بني البشر يستحقون وضعا امنا سواء
كان سودانيين او اجانب ولكن طالما ان هناك
من خرج وذهب الى اهله امنا المطمئنا
وبسلامه كان ايضا في ضد اللحظات يمكن
للقوتين المتقاتلين ان تسمح ولو بعدد من
الممرات الامنه للمهندسين او هيئه مياه
ولايه الخرطوم الان تصلح عدد من القطوعات
المياه ان تفتح عدد من المستشفيات او طرق
الاسعاف لعدد من المرضى من الامراض
المزمنه او الجرح ى او حتى ان تسمح لعدد
من الاسر ان تتلقى التعافي فيما فقدته من
خلال هذه المامون
عدد من الجثث التي هي ربما الان تبلع عدد
من شوارع
من هدنه صحيح وهذا المامول وهذا ما يعمل
عليه كذلك
دخل سوداني وحتى يعني بعض الاطراف داخل
السودان وحتى المجتمع الدولي ساعود لك
تتفضل بالباقه معي عمار ابو شيبه الصحفي
ساعود لك بعد لحظات بعد التفكير ببعض
الاخبار ذات الصله حيث تتواصل عمليه اجراء
الرعايه الاجانب والبعثات الدبلوماسيه من
العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم نحو بورتسودان
بسبب تدهور الوضع الامني الناتج عن الصراع
الحاصل بين المكونين العسكريين
[موسيقى]
من جديد اليك عمار ابو شيبه الصحفي من
خرطوم بحري ولكن قبل المتابعه نشير الى
هذا العاجل وزير الخارجيه السعودي يبحث مع
نظيره القطري جهود وقف التصعيد في السودان
اذا كما نتابع من خلال عواجل العربيه لحظه
بلحظه للتطورات وزير الخارجيه السعوديه
يبحث مع نظيره القطري جهود وقف التصعيد في
السودان عمار اعود لك واعود بتحديد عمليه
الاجلاء كنا تحدثنا مع مراسلنا في ما يخص
عمليه الاجلاء وقال بان عاده هذه العمليه
تتم في مطارات عسكريه وفرنسا كانت خصصت
مطار يبعد عن مطار الخرطوم 20 كم لاجلاء
رعاياها هل تعطينا المزيد من التفاصيل حول
هذه المطارات اسماء
كم عددها ما هي المطارات المتوفره لعمليه
الاجلاء
نعم يعني عمليات الاجلاء خاصه اذا رجعنا
الى بروتوكول هو موديل عمليات الاجلاء
خاصه في عدد من الدول التي جرت بها حروب
مشابهه نلاحظ ان هنالك تكون مناطق
استراتيجيه خاصه بالقوات المسلحه او مناطق
محيده وتكون هنالك اطراف داخل هذه المناطق
مثلا الهلال الاحمر بشاهدنا في عدد من
الفترات شاهدناه بالامس مثلا قد يعني ساعد
كثيرا جدا في تسليم عدد من الجنود
المصريين الذين كانوا محتاجين لدى عدد من
القوات قوات الدعم السريع وتسليمهم الى
الطائرات مصريه تم نقله من خلالها الى
العاصمه المصريه القاهره هذه الاطراف تسعى
من خلال مناطق يتم تحديدها او مناطيه يتم
اختيارها يمكن لطائراتها عسكريه ان تهبط
على مهابط ارضيه خاصه اذا كانت هذه
الطائرات عموديه يمكن ان تهبط في مناطق
شاسعه مثلا في اطراف العاصمه الخرطوم
الولايات الجزيره هنالك عدد من المناطق
التي دائما ما يتم استخدامها في مثلها كذا
يعني مشاكل او مثلها كذا صراعات او
الاذاعات هذه العمليات هي عمليات نوعيه
وهنالك تابعنا في الاخبار بان البحريه
الامريكيه وسلاح الجو البريطاني ربما
اتفقا في عمليه انزال وعمليه تامين باكثر
من 100 جندي وهذا يدل على ان هذه العمليات
لحساسه وخطر وربما هنالك كثير جدا من
التقارير الامنيه اشارت الى ان استحاله ان
تتم هذه العمليات عمليات الخروج والاجلال
عدد من الرعايه الغربيين وعدد من الرعايه
عمار لانها قريبه من الاشتباكات
نعم صحيح وهذا الوصف بالخطيره ربما هو ما
يؤكد ان هنالك اصابه اصابه كانت بطلق
النار العدد من الرعايه المصريين للبيع في
الدبلوماسيه هذا ما تبعنا في الاخبار
وهنالك ايضا يعني اخبار تتحدث عن وفيات
الاجانب جراء عمليات القوات او الاشتباك
ما بين القوتين وفي الايام الفائته فهذا
كله يعني
خطرا للغايه على الارض يصعب من خلاله
عمليه تحريك مدنيين ما لم تكن هنالك بدائل
او تكن هنالك نقاط يمكن للجانبين ان
يتوقفوا عندها مثلا كالهلال الاحمر او
الصليب الاحمر الذين استطاعوا ان يسهلوا
كثير جدا من عمل
عمليه الاجلاء بنسبه كبيره جدا ايضا يعني
الحديث عن هدنه في هذا الوقت الراهن هو
لابد ان يفرض ان تفرض هذه الهدنه حتى من
القوات يعني ان يقتنع المتقاتلين
عن الهدنه صحيح ولكن قبل الحديث عن الهدنه
عمليه الاجراء في حد ذاتها لتتم ليصل
الرعايه اي بلد للمطار المحدد او من
المحدد يجب تامين كذلك الطريق من يشرف على
هذه العمليه في داخل السوداني
يعني تابعنا عدد من الاخبار وهنا الحديث
ربما يكون حساسيه عاليه لان كلا الطرفين
كان يتحدث عن انه من قام بعمليه الاجلاء
او انه من سهل عمليه الاجلاء وهنا ربما
تفرض حسابات
الامن بنسبه كبيره جدا خياراتها يعني من
يبسط سيطرته بشكل واضح على عدد من المناطق
العسكريه هو من يسهل هذه العمليه يعني
هنالك كان بيان للخارجيه الامريكيه تحدثت
بان قوات الدعم السريع لم تشكل اي سند لها
في عمليه الاجلال عدد من الرعايه هذا
الصباح بل كان دورها يختصر فقط على عدم
اطلاق النار وهنالك حديث كان من الجانب
الاخر بانهم من جانب القوات المسلحه بانهم
امنوا هذه النقطه او او امنوا عدد المناطق
لعدد من الرعايه حتى يتم من خلالها عمليه
الحركه شاهدنا في عدد من المقاطع التي
نشرت قبل قليل على عدد من شاشات التلفزه
لوفد من اليونسيف او من الامم المتحده
يقوم عمليه اجلاء وبرضه مشترك يبدو انه من
البعثه الدوليه شاهدنا هذه اللقطه قبل
قليل كانت هناك عربات او سيارات عسكريه
لقوات من الدعم السريع داخل هذه عمليه
الاجلاق وهذا ربما هو بالتوازي او
بالاحتكاك في هذه المنطقه كانت تتواجد
فيها قوات الدعم السريع او ربما تذهب مره
اخرى الى منطقه اخرى ويتواجد فيها
القوات المسلحه السودانيه
شكر عمار ابو شيبه صحفي كنت معنا من
الخرطوم بحري شكرا جزيلا على المشاركه
الناس كلها سكان بحريه يعني شبه كل سكان
يعني
ثمانيه ايام بالليله في بدايه الاحداث لم
يعني لم تجد اننا ماء تماما ولا يوجد
عندنا كهرباء
مشاهدينا تطورات سياسيه وعسكريه متسارعه
شهدها السودان منذ اسقاط النظام عمر
البشير عام 2019 بدايه من المظاهرات
الحاشده وبتشكيل مجلس السياده وصولا الى
تطورات الاخيره والحرب التي انفجرت بين
المكونين العسكريين والتي تنظر بعوده
الازمه الى المربع الاول
في السودان الصراع متوصل بين المكونين
العسكريين
ايام المره يعيشها السودانيون الذين
تطلعوا لعهد جديد تميزه الديمقراطيه
حياه العشرات تحولت لماساه حقيقيه بسبب
تدهور الوضع الامني صراع تلو اخر عمق
الازمه وزاد من حده التململ والاستياء
ملامح الحزن والاسى خيمت على وجه ادريس
حسان الذي فقد ابن اخيه عندما اخترقت
قذيفه النافذه المنزل ادت لمقتله على
سريره
[موسيقى]
على الاجزال الليله فقدناه
والمرحوم ده
بس يعني
القصف تسبب بحروق لوالده الضحيه التي صدمت
من هول الحادثه حاول علي خربت علي
والله
[موسيقى]
الحياه المدنيه توقفت في السودان
مناطق سكنيه مقتظه بالسكان ومضخمه بالرصاص
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا نتابع مع كل هذه التطورات من
انجمينا من تشاد ينضم لنا الاعلامي علي
فاضل علي اهلا بك معنا الامم المتحده كانت
تحدثت عن نزوح بين 10 الى 20,000 من
النساء والاطفال باتجاه تشاد هل معك
مبدئيا تفاصيل اضافيه هل هناك اعداد من
جهه التشاد قيمت وقدمت بطريقه رسميه
اهلا وسهلا حتى الان ما في احصائيه دقيقه
للاجئين السودانيين الذين دخلوا على
الاراضي التشاديه حتى الان لكن
هناك في اخبار تتوارث من المناطق الحدوديه
بان هناك عدد كبير جدا من العائلات
السودانيه غالبيتهم من النساء والعنصر
الشبابي والاطفال دخلوا الى الاراضي
الشعبيه وكما تعرفينه ويعرف الجميع ان
هناك عدد نازحين
متواجدين في الاراضي الشعبيه منذ 20 عاما
يعني منذ اندلاع
الصراع في دارفور عام 2003 كانت استقبلت
عادات كبيره من اللاجئين وهؤلاء اللاجئين
اللي موجودين في الاراضي التجاريه منذ 20
عاما حتى الان لم يرجعوا الى ديارهم وجاءت
هذه الحربه لتزيد الطين ادله كما يقولون
فالعادات كبيره جدا وصليب الاحمر اشار الى
انهم حتى الان الاعداد التي دخلت تتراوح
ما بين 10,000 الى 20,000 لكن ما في
احصائيه العدد يفوق هذا هذا العدد الذي
تحدثت عنه منظمه الصليب الاحمر طيب تحدثت
عن اعداد كبيره وتحدثت عن اعداد سابقتها
منذ حرب دارفور منذ 2003 هناك عدد كبير من
النازحين ومن اللاجئين الذين توجهوا الى
تشاد بالنسبه للاعداد الحاليه عند دخولهم
ما هي الترتيبات كيف يتم استقبالهم كيف
يتم مرورهم الى اين يتوجهون كيف يعيشون
ان القبائل التجاريه
السودان فكثير من لديهم عائلاتنا في تاب
فهم البعض منهم ممكن يطيل مع عائلاتهم في
بعض من الممكن يقين في
المناطق التي
جهزتها لهم السلطات التجاريه كما تعرفين
النشات قبل اسبوع ارسلت هناك قوه امنيه
قوه عسكريه لتامين المنطقه الحدوديه بينها
تشاد السودان تحسبا لاي صراع او لاي
انفلات امنيه ممكن يحصل في المنطقه
الحدوديه فهؤلاء الذين ذهبوا الى تامين
المناطق الحدوديه معهم فاطم طبي معهم طلاق
انسانيه تستقبل اللاجئين الذين ياتون من
الاراضي السودانيه وكذلك الصليب الاحمر
ايضا حتى الان اقام بعض المقيمات لاستقبال
الاعداد الجديده
المقبل الى الى دوله شاهد وكما تعرفين
ايضا النشاد استقبلت كما قلت في بدايه
حديثي تقريبا تقريبا 100000 سوداني يقيمون
في الاراضي الكاديه
بعائلاتهم
منذ 20 عاما هؤلاء استقروا في المنطقه
الحدوديه فهؤلاء ايضا
عائلاتهم القادمه من من الاراضي السودانيه
بسبب الحروبات او بسبب الحرب المندليها
حاليا
له عائله يتوجه لها طيب ولكن قلت بان
السلطات التشاديه جهزت كذلك مناطق جديده
لاستقبال اللاجئين حدثني عن الطاقم الطبيه
والاغاثيه ولكن ماذا في تفاصيل هذه
المناطق كيف جهزتها سلطه شاديه
اند
لعت لسيكون احد يتوقع ان هذه الحربه تاتي
بهذه الوتيره وبهذه السرعه فلذلك حتى
السلطات الكاديه لم تكن جاهزه
لتجهيز الطواقم الطبيه او الطواقم
الانسانيه ولكن الطواخم الطبيه والتراكم
الانسانيه التي ارسلتها هذه طواقي مرافقه
للجنود الكادين الذين يفهمون الى تامين
المنطقه الحدوديه
تعاون اني معهم ممكن تكون امكانيه ضعيفه
ليست امكانيه كافيه لاستقبال عادات كبيره
ولكن ربما ربما هؤلاء الذين ذهبوا لتامين
المنطقه الحدوديه بين السوداني يستعينون
بي الصليب الاحمر الدولي لربما يجهزوا بعض
الامر الاماكن كما جهزوها من قبل
جاهزه والمنطقه الحدوديه جاهزه نسبه لان
الصراع لم يكون ولي اليوم انه الصراع
صحيح ولكن علي هذه المناطق فيها مخيمات
يعني لما تتحدث عن مناطق مجهزه هي عباره
على مخيمات صحيح
فانها صراحه هي جاءت في موسم صعب
الله سبحانه وتعالى ان يستتب الامن في
السودان اود شكرك جزيلا الشكر علي فاضل
الاعلاميه كنت معنا من انجمينا في التشاد
شكرا لك
ومشاهدينا كانت افادت مصادر العربيه
باعطاء مصر الضوء الاخضر لبدء عمليات
الاجرام من السودان حيث قالت المصادر ان
الجيش المصري ينسق مع نظيره السوداني لبدء
العمليات كما اشارت مصادر العربيه ان
الجيش السوداني سيتولى مرافقه قوافل
المصريين حتى المعابر الحدوديه وان
السودان زود مصر بتفاصيل الممرات الامنه
لنقل المصريين لاماكن الاجلاء وكانت مصر
نشرات قوات امنيه على معابره الحدوديه مع
السودان لتامين عمليه الاجلاء
وكانت بدات في السودان اولى عمليه اجراء
الجاليه الموريتانيه من الخرطوم وذلك
بمساعده من السعوديه وتم خلال عمليه
الاجلاء تفويج نساء واطفال الجاليه في
بورتسودان وسيتم نقل ذلك في باخره سعوديه
الى الميناء
قال رئيس الوزراء البريطاني ريشوناك قال
ان القوات المسلحه اتمت عمليه اجراء معقده
وسريعه للدبلوماسيين البريطانيين ولعائلته
من السودان مضيفا ان بريطانيا تسعى بكل
الوسائل لوقف اراقه الدماغ في السودان
وضمان سلامه البريطانيين المتبقين هناك
وانها تحف الاطراف كافه على القاء الاسلحه
في اطلاق النار
قال وزير الدفاع البريطاني بانوالاس على
صفحته على تويتر قال ان القوات المسلحه
البريطانيه نفذت عمليه عسكريه الى جانب
الولايات المتحده وفرنسا وحلفاء اخرين
واجلت موظفي السفاره البريطانيه وعائلاتهم
من الخرطوم بسبب تهديدات المتصاعده مشيرا
الى مشاركه 1200 جون بريطاني في العمليه
اكثر منهم سته عشر لواء هجوم جوي ومشاه
البحريه الملكيه والسلاح الجو الملكي
البريطاني
على صعيد جهود الدوليه والاقليميه بحث
وزير الخارجيه السعوديه الامير فيصل بن
فرحان مع مسؤول السياسه الخارجيه في
الاتحاد الاوروبي جوزيف بوريل بحث الجهود
المبذوله لوقف التصعيد العسكري بين
الاطراف المتنازعه وانهاء العنف في
السودان اضافه الى توفير الحمايه اللازمه
للمدنيين السودانيين والمقيمين مسؤول
سياسه الخارجيه في الاتحاد الاوروبي كشف
عن توافق صعودي اوروبي على العمل الجماعي
من اجل وقف اطلاق النار في السودان
متابعه هذا الموضوع مع ضيفنا الكاتب
الصحفي عبد الشكور عبد الصمد سيد عبد
الشكور يبدو بان العنوان الرئيس لهذا
اليوم مع
الهدوء الحذر ولكن قبل ان اعود لك استاذ
عبد الشكور ساعود لك لمناقشه هذا التطورات
ولكن اسمح لي هناك صور تردنا الان هذه
الصور
نتابعها لبعض الاشتباكات في الخرطوم هذه
صور مباشره لبعض الاشتباكات التي شهدتها
الخرطوم بين الدعم السريع وقوات الجيش
سنبقى مع هذه الصور
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
المشاهدين اكون في متابعه لهذا الفيديو
الذي اظهر اشتباكات شهدها احد الاحياء في
الخرطوم اعود لك من جديد سيده عبد الشكور
عبد الصمد كنا نتحدث عن عمليات الاجلاء
ويبدو بان العنوان الرئيس اليوم مع
ربما تراجع نسق الاشتباكات هو عمليات
اجلاء مستمره نتابعها بين الفين والاخرى
عمليه الاجلاء هذه بما توحي
اهلا وسهلا
حقيقه وانا استمع الى المقطع الذي لا يعني
قاطعتيني فيه وفي خلفيته الاطفال الذين
يبكون
مقطع مؤسف الحقيقه هي اشتباكات شهدها
الخرطوم
شيء مؤلم حقيقه
فهذا في
للجميع في الواقع سيد عبده الشكور صوت
يتقطع سيد عبد الشكور هل تسمعني انا
اكمل
مجتمع الدوله يتخلى عن شعبه السوداني
وياخذ رعاياه وياخذ
افراده وهذه حقيقه ليست هي هذه هذا ليس
دور المجتمع الدولي كان بامكان المجتمع
الدولي ان يتدخل
بقرض وقت اطلاق النار ويجبر الطرفين على
وقف اطلاق النار هذا هو المفترض بالفعل
كما راينا العديد من البعثات الدبلوماسيه
اخذت رعاياها ما بين
عبر قمرين والولايات المتحده بسته عشر
طائره
وعبر اديس ابابا وعبر ايضا وايضا هناك عبر
بورد سودان
المملكه العربيه السعوديه
بسلاح البحر
اخذت رعايه 16 دوله من مختلف العالم
كما ورد في تقرير ايضا فرنسا وبريطانيا
لكن حقيقه ليس هنا
مربط الفرس هو ان يتم
السعي الى الى وقف اطلاق النار هو هذا
الذي كان يفترض ان يقوم به المجتمع السيد
عبد الشكور هذا يبدو السؤال الاصعب في هذه
المرحله لانك بمتابعه تصريحات الطرفين
هناك حرب كسر عظام في هذه الفتره ونحن
نتحدث وليست هناك اي مؤشرات لوقف اطلاق
النار لما تقول بان على المجتمع الدولي ان
يؤثر على هذه الاطراف لوقف لاطلاق النار
كيف ما الضغوط التي يمكن ان تؤثر في
الطرفين
ما دور مجلس الامن والامم المتحده ما هو
دور الاتحاد الافريقي مجلس السلم والامن
الافريقي هذه المؤسسات يجب ان يكون عندها
دور اساسي
قامت لاجله وهو حمايه مصالح الشعوب
بامكان هناك اطراف اقليميه واطراف دوليه
بامكانها ان تفرض
وقت اطلاق النار على على الاطراف
المتحاربه وايضا هناك مسؤوليه حقيقه على
على النخب السياسيه السودانيه يجب عليها
ان
تخضع ان تخضع الاطراف المتحاربه
للاسف في حقيقه يعني زهره شباب المجتمع
السوداني الشعبي السوداني يحصد بعشرات
الالاف في هذه الحرب هو هنا السن المؤلمه
البعض يقول سيد عبد الشكور بان هذه الازمه
هي ازمه بين قائدين بين جنرين بين شخصين
احد الصحف الامريكيه عن ونات بانها حرب
الغيره بين شخصين هل هناك نفس القراءه
فداخل السوداني لهذه الحرب مما دفع شريحه
كبيره بناء بنفسها عن هذا التصعيد
قد يكون يعني الطرفان المتحاربان هم هما
يعني راسها الحرب لكن حقيقه
القضيه اعمق من ذلك هناك اطراف اقليميه
واطراف دوليه من مصلحتها ان يحدث هذا في
السودان ومن مصلحتها ايضا يعني نحن في
افريقيا هناك
القاره الافريقيه والسودان واحده من
المعابر من المنافذ الرئيسيه الى افريقيا
قبل ثلاثه قبل سنتين اليوم يتكرر في
السودان
حقيقه يعني القوه السياسيه السودانيه ايضا
تتحمل جزء من يعني هذا ما عبرت عنه السيده
مريم الصادق عندما قالت نحن وانا واحده من
هؤلاء الناس تحمل المسؤوليه عليهم امثالا
ان يقوموا الان
بلوره نداء مجتمعي حتى يستطيع ان يضغط على
على العسكر لكي يوقف وحمام الدمالة ولاحظ
هذه الفكره اسمح لي ان اعود لك بعد قليل
كذلك لرصد الاوضاع كونك صحفي استاذ عبد
الشكور اكيد بانك متابع لحاله المستشفيات
والحاله عموما في داخل السوداني في ظل هذه
الازمه ولكن تفضل بالبقاء معي مشاهدينا
سنذهب لنتابع هذا المقطع الخاص بالعربيه
لرصد عائلات عربيه تم اجلائها من الخرطوم
الى المتابع
مدير منتجع الساحه
الخرطوم انا من 17 سنه بها البلد حبينا
السودان حبينا اهل السودان
السودان فجاه
الحارس علينا وعلى الناس كلها بدون بدون
سابق انذار
فعلا فعلا كانت
ساقط على الناس كلها علينا
حاليا الخرطوم تركناها
فعلا حزينه ما فيها ما فيها حدا
اهميه تبعنا الاستثمار تبعنا استثمارات
كثيره على الارض
تدمري طلعنا انا طلعت بهي الكنزه
اسفي عبدك السودان او بلد زي السودان يحصل
له بلد النيلين يحصل له
تبعت ايام قعدنا
تحت الضغط الن
فسي تحت يعني
عشنا عشنا
والحمد لله يعني قدرنا
الاخير انه املنا
نجلاء لبنانيه مثل ما كل الدول عم
طلعنا الصباح
حضرتكم شايفين انه هلا
السعوديه
كلمه الاخيره هي فعلا انا حاطلع
والتمعه بعيوني
كنا في متابعه هذا التسجيل العربيه تلتقي
عائلات عربيه تم اجلائها من الخرطوم الى
بورتسودان وتابعنا هذا اللقاء مع احد
الذين تم اجلائهم اعود لكم من جديد سيد
عبد الشكور كنا نتحدث عن الشبكات متقطعه
وحدثنا كذلك مراسلنا منذ قليل عن حاله
هدوء حذر تشهدها الخرطوم حضرتك متابع
لتفاصيل تداعيات مشاهدناه الايام السابقه
الى اي مدى تضررت المستشفيات مبدئيا وهل
بهذا الهدوء الحظر هناك شبه عوده لعملها
كما كانت بطريقه طبيعيه او شبه طبيعيه
اختي الكريمه هناك حديث بانه الكثير من
المستشفيات الرئيسيه في مدن الثلاثه
الخرطوم والخرطوم بحري وام درمان خرجت من
الخدمه
باعتبار تعرضها لوقف اطلاق النار المباشر
وباعتبار انه ايضا استخدمت بعضها حقيقه من
من القوات الدعم السريع وايضا
باعتبار قربها من الاحداث يعني مستشفى
الخرطوم التعليمي قريب من القياده
نفس الشيء ايضا مستشفى الشرطه خرج من
الخدمه
الكهرباء مقطوعه
والمياه مقطوعه وايضا حقيقه
هذه المستشفيات لم تعد للعمل ولو بطريقه
جزئيه صحيح حتى هذه اللحظه
المستشفى فطومه التعليمي خرج من الخدمه
ونفس الامر مستشفى الشرطه
وهناك المستشفيات الاخرى حقيقه مثل صلاح
الطبي هذه كلها يعني يتواجد فيها عناصر
الدعم السريع فبالتالي يعني للاسف الشديد
عامه الناس الجثث موجوده في الشوارع
والحاله حقيقه صعبه صعبه جدا
يلطف باهلنا في السودان وان تنفرج هذه
الغمه في اسرع وقت ممكن وهنا هو حقيقه
المجتمع الدولي انا دائما
اكرر انه على المجتمع الدولي يجب ان يكون
له موقف اقوى من هذا بكثير
وهناكور تتحدث عن المجتمع الدولي ولكن منذ
قليل كذلك حدثتني عن دور الداخل السوداني
دور المكون السياسي بحسب اعتقادك من من
الشخصيات السياسيه القادره ان تؤثر على
طرفي النزاع في هذه المرحله
للاسف الشديد
السيوله السياسيه الموجوده في الشارع
السوداني جعلت هناك استنزاف للرصيد الشعبي
لهذه للشخصيات المجتمعيه
يعني هناك تصنيف
يعني للقامات العلميه والاجتماعيه
وللثقافيه يعني يعني هناك مؤسساتي مجتمع
مدني موجوده لكن للاسف يعني
الاصطفاف جعل الناس حقيقه يكون في بعض لكن
اتمنى ان يكون يبادر الانديه الرياضيات
الاجتماعيه اتمنى المساجد لكل لها دور
ايجابي
والمؤسسات الدينيه بصفه عامه يجب ان يكون
لها دور ايجابي ويسمع كلمتها حقيقه يعني
يجب ان يكون هناك
يجب ان يكون
ونحن نتحدث شكور فقط اسمح لي ونحن نتحدث
نتابع هذه الصور المباشره من الخرطوم
ونسمع اصوات اطلاق نار واصوات قذائف كذلك
ساكتفي معك بهذا القدر عبد الشكور عبد
الصمد الصحفي كنت معنا من نادي سببا شكرا
جزيلا لك
سودان عبر الهاتف نائب امين عام شباب
المجلس الاعلى للنظرات البيجا محمد سيدنا
سيد محمد اهلا بك معنا كنتم في لقاءات
سابقه على العربيه وكذلك على العربيه
الحدث تحدثتم عن دعمكم للقوات المسلحه
ولكن عن رايكم بنفسكم عن هذا الصراع وانكم
لن تتدخلوا في هذا الصراع طيب ولكن ماذا
عن الوساطه هل انتم قادرون على الدخول
بمقترح وساطه بين الطرفين
بسم الله والصلاه والسلام على رسول الله
نستعين كل عام وانتم
يعني الى الاصابه السودان ونتراهم جندي
بلادي السودان
ويتقبلا من قبول الحسن
ونحن يعني الحمد لله شاركنا في
جلابات المتجهه للشرق السودان غدا بئس
السفير المملكه العربيه المتحده
وسفير
الكويتي
والليبي والهندي
قام مطابقه دقيقه مع الهدف توجيهات رئيس
مجلس البنا
ونستغنى مع الاخ والولايه المدارك وكسله
حتى وصلوا الى ميناء بورسودان واتجهوا الى
جده
نحن نناشد السيد رئيس مجلس السياده
الانتقالي
وقائد الدعم السريع هو التي ولدت بالرحمه
القوات المسلحه نتمنى انه يرجعوا لصوت
الاغلب والحكمه حتى لا تندلع الفتنه في
المكونات
نحن في
سيد محمد هذه المناشده تقدمتم بها بطريقه
فعليه يعني تتواصلون مع الطرفين
والله ليس لدينا تواصل مع الاخ النائب
مجلس السياده والرئيس نحن في اقليم شرق
السودان من
منذ ثوره ديسمبر بنرى هذه الفتنه بتتجول
في كل الولايات وفي المكونات والصراع
القبل للمره بها السودان ولكن المجتمع
السوداني المجتمع بتاع حكمه ونزعنا من هذا
الفتنه
والمثل الربيع السودان ولكن الفتنه ما
قامت بها ما يسمى بالاطار
العاليه الرباعيه والخماسيه
نفسه
الاممي بوركر
انجلت الفتنه بسبب هذه
العمليه السياسيه
دون
استشاره دون
الاتحاد من كل الاقاليم وفرضوا نفسهم
انزلت من هذا السبب ونحن نناسب
الدعم السريع انه يرجع للهكمه ويسلم نفسه
للغواط الشعب المصلحه ويعلن انضمامه
للقوات الشعب المسلح الباكده او شكرك جزيل
الشكر نائب امين عام شباب المجلس الاعلى
للنظرات البيجا محمد سيدنا شكرا لك
الله اكبر
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
في اخبار اخرى ذات الصله اعلن المتحدث
باسم العمليه السياسيه في السودان خالد
عمر يوسف اعلن ان النزاع الحاليه في
السودان سيكون سببا في ضياع البلاد دون
استعادتها مؤكدا انها حرب لن ينتصر فيها
اي طرف المتحدث اشار الى الفرصه المتاحه
لايقاف الحرب وتشكيل جبهه مدنيه مناهضه
للحرب كما اكد على اهميه هو اولويه اجتماع
الاطراف العسكريه والمدنيه على طويله
الحوار للتوصل لحل دائم
هذا وكانت اعلنت وزاره الصحه السودانيه عن
تعذر استقبال المرضى في مركز الغسيل
الكلوي في مستشفى النوم وتوقف الخدمه فيه
الصحه قالت بانها تعاني من نقص الكوادر
العامله في المركز وتقدس المرضى فيه كما
دعت الكوادر الطبيه القريبه مركز النوب
العمل في لمساعده المرضى ونرشدات
المتطوعين واهالي المرضى بتوفير المسكن
والحوافز لاستقبال المرضى وذلك في ظل غياب
المسؤولين في وزاره الصحه الاتحاديه
ووزاره الصحه في ولايه الخرطوم
اعلن مدير منظمه الصحه العالميه ان
المؤسسات الصحيه في السودان تعرضت لهجمات
ويجب ان تتوقف على الفور واكدات تدرس انه
لا ينبغي استهدافه مقدميه الرعايه الصحيه
او المرافق الحيه والمرضى في السودان
صرح وزير خارجيه جنوب السودان للعربيه بان
جنوب السودان قامت باستقبال اكثر من 3000
لاجئ من السودان ومساعده لاستقبال المزيد
منهم كما قال بان رئيس جنوب السودان اجرى
مكالمه هاتفيه مع رئيس المصري لحث البرهان
على الموافقه لوقف اطلاق النار
لقد قمنا باستقبال مجموعه من السودانيين
لسنوات عده وامنا ما ولاهم ونحن سعيدون
لهذا ولدينا اكثر من 3000 لاجئ من السودان
يعيشون بكرامه في جنوب السودان ونحن
مستعدون لاستقبال المزيد منهم ان رئيسنا
اجر مكالمه هاتفيه مع الرئيس المصري وتطرق
للوضع الحالي وكيف يمكنهم العمل على حث
البرهان لوقف اطلاق النار والعوده الى
طاوله المفاوضات وذلك لوقف الخلافات بين
الطرفين المتحاربين
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات